hi y'all man my name is Pam DVR Huggins
it's my boy Mike right here you know
we're we trying to make it like a little
document everything and whatnot we
really are liking more chairs and less
rules more music auditor hey hey we got
an idea tell us if you like this idea we
already like floated this one like
sometimes bands they play two different
places like what if they all play the
same place at the same time right yeah
everybody I'm sorry John was making
lemonade and whatnot
and I was think sometimes what you want
to do is like put comedy up into like
what you've been doing would you be
willing like you make like a lemonade
and then you're like like that go like
this to be like and I said oh it's on
lemonade is that P juice see and in this
like a mystery for them you know I'm
talking about that make it better you
know you don't think so you know I think
y'all man y'all got corn dogs right
giant giant corn dogs missing corn dogs
see y'all y'all should be selling giant
porn dogs see see that's funny man
and in the comedy you can put the comedy
inside the food I'm talking about burn
man what's that big Burning Man yeah how
do I have a burning man back you're like
a wicker man it set him on fire right or
like a big pretzel right something like
that the Bugs Bunny's dick
yes and then burn his dick like set his
little wicked dick on fire let me be
like this like a wicker man and have
like a like it's like a dick like this
and they just be like everything is
through lemonade lemonade man oh
oh yeah you know what you asked to do
but I think we'll be good don't like a
sort of some comedy into it yes if y'all
said you didn't you'd like your dick out
to be this high I can't get a ruler out
yeah every single person Manny's got to
be up to here oh yeah
okay oh hey hey I'm cool with that
can I be here to see that though and I'm
witness valuation and I'll get a witness
yeah I won't be no witness thanks man I
appreciate it
so is it tips or chips see that's funny
right here thank you thanks Chelsea all
right Sarah is that right
like Sarah Connors like in a terminator
I mean seriously you also put that like
Bernie man with a burning dick Oh hold
on give it just give us some thought
you